[Music]
so I don't know about you guys but I
totally have had this thought crossed my
mind during this whole situation where
I'm like man cuz you guys know how I
recently went to Bora Bora for my
birthday in November like man imagine I
was in Bora Bora when all this should
happen and then what a perfect place to
be 14 how would have been amazing what
and you're not allowed to leave yeah
gonna be the [ __ ] month exactly so
there are there's this couple who has
been interviewed by the New York Times
and they were the last couple in their
resort in the Maldives and so they had
to be there they okay so they went all
know the tragedy so they went for their
honeymoon and they got their March I
think the 22nd those 22nd there were a
lot of people at that same resort where
they were like oh my god we gotta get
home like this is crazy like they're
they're closing the airports are closing
that's what we worst at home than it is
at Bora Bora
so this couples like these couples like
suckers we have this place to ourselves
no this couple was like okay we got to
get home too so they're from South
Africa and so they ended up hitting up
there the embassy there and they were
saying like oh yeah there's about 40
other South Africans and the Maldives I
threw it scattered throughout the
islands and so your current option right
now because the airport has closed you
can get a private like charter jet but
you would have to pay at your own
expense which is one hundred and four
thousand dollars oh so you can't laid it
up between the two dozen couples that
are there but there were a lot of people
that were like [ __ ] don't worry I'm not
gonna we're not gonna pay so the more
people bail the more expensive it gets
per person and so this particular couple
they decided like [ __ ] like what do we
do so they were almost going to get on a
speed boat and go into the main island
to see what they can like how they can
get out and but the resort said if you
leave we can't let you come back so make
your decision so then they decided okay
let's let's not go that stage what about
all the people to resort
today I'll leave two thing the resort
has a policy that no employee can leave
until the last guest has left this
couple was the very last two people left
so everyone hates them hold on but
honestly I looked at the situation and
I'm like out of everyone involved here
the best case scenario for like the best
person that benefited would be the
employees because they got paid
throughout the whole time to keep their
jobs they get to keep their jobs I get
to get paid and after this couple
finally they were finally able to leave
the employees there had to still stay
there for another two weeks to be
quarantine like make sure that they
didn't have anything before they can
leave the resort but they're gonna paint
that whole time so it seems like they
got the sweetest deal and they probably
got to stay at though at the rooms
they're just chilling with each other ya
know is not this thing you know is going
in around all they're getting paid they
see it that way I just play no role in I
want to read this like little excerpt of
the New York Times cuz just painting
this scene I was reading this and I'm
like oh my god that's crazy they doing a
New York accent no so this is the
resort's full staff or at hand because
of the prep presence of the two guest
government regulations won't allow any
meld Debian's to leave the resort until
after they undergo a quarantine that
follows their Alaska's departure
accustomed to the flow of the bustling
workday because during this time of year
it's like at capacity this place is oh
my god
most of the staff having grown listless
and lonely dot on the couple ceaselessly
there were like kings and queens in
their room boy checks on them five times
a day the dining crew made them an
elaborate candlelit dinner every night
performers still put on a show for them
in the resort's restaurant where they're
just the only two audience members at
breakfast nine waiters loiter by their
table hostesses buzzers and
or did chefs circulate conspicuously
like commoners near a celebrity
the couple has a designated server but
others still come by to chat during
their meals topping off water glasses
after each sip offering drinks even
cocktail glasses stand in full view the
diving instructor pleads with them to go
snorkeling whenever they pass him by
[Laughter]
they should have had one of us do this
because we would be way more creative
than to just take all that [ __ ] well at
least for me I do that for one day and
I'll be like alright tomorrow it's gonna
be your turn and we're gonna perform and
everyone just [ __ ] rotate you know I
mean like I wanna [ __ ] be a cook for
a day and in a diving instructor for it
down there like policies that's how Joe
burns down the whole resort yeah I'm
doing like a Polynesian fire dancing
show and [ __ ] the whole resort this is a
couple from South Africa can't even see
them dude that looks beautiful wherever
that you can't you can't see them okay
okay I see him now I thought they were
like blocking themselves because they're
so ashamed of how [ __ ] lost where's
the map that's on the side of India oh
this is beautiful
yeah that's where to into your head
there there it's like little islands in
the Indian Ocean oh my god that is so
you'd like the only one in the entire
restaurant where this time of year it's
like jam-packed like packed pépin yet
bomb-ass room in the chef like only
needs to focus on his dish excess amount
of food probably cuz they prepare for
the bad amount of ghastly I think the
limit the capacity is like 180 guests or
something it's all-inclusive I don't
know but the thing is that they did
mention that they even though it is like
a discounted rate
they still are getting charged every
single day that they spend there so for
them they're like but like you know
they're newlyweds for like damn it we
were say
we had a down payment for a house every
day that we're here it's eating at our
savings
what is that cheaper than flying back
though see sounds like a hundred four
thousand you know I'd rather just stay
there but so did everyone else charter
the plane and they're the ones that said
[ __ ] it no so eventually the embassy hit
them up on April 5th and said like okay
in one hour you need to have all your
[ __ ] packed cuz you're gonna get on a
speedboat like there James Bond
I'm staying [ __ ] y'all
yeah so then no cuz you're gonna go
broke you're getting charged everything
because they have to pay the staff to
well they weren't as creative as me
which is all work one do you make your
money back so I'm gonna work there's the
money coming from from one of the staff
there are gonna guess there and we're
gonna take turns or they could they
could open that only fans account and
charge all the staff for the minutes
make money so eventually they were taken
to taken to another five five-star rest
that's where the rest of the South
Africans left in the Maldives were there
about two dozen and all and the local
government told them that they would
subsidize a large portion of their the
cost of their stay so I don't know I'm
kind of curious I'm like how much like
did it end up saving you money because
of all this like the vacation you were
gonna take anyway I love listening to
these stories where people just benefit
from a crisis what a happy accident
isn't a benefit though do they have
access to Netflix and Amazon I would go
crazy if every single day I don't know I
find some fun [ __ ] to do it's so
gorgeous but you do that kind of get a
little bored cuz there were some days
where I was just there and I'm like cuz
I was trying not to get on my phone at
all yeah I was just there like staring
at the beautiful water and I'm like know
what I [ __ ] jack off on the beach I
realized during this quarantine I don't
have the ability to be bored I'll find
some [ __ ] I will I will chase a crab for
hours
you know to me like I'll find some [ __ ]
like car to charity yeah do something
yeah I'll find something like oh I can
already store coal for just like four
hours
you just follow a fish around you know
then you come out and then my back
sunburnt on like cows in the water for
that long I will [ __ ] create a dance
troupe with Maldivian and we will battle
like the [ __ ] lunch crew you know I
mean like be in the water all day every
day
gonna turn it to a crab but I couldn't
because of my son allergy like my skin
was [ __ ] like I came back with like so
many crashes full body just swim out in
a wetsuit a bikini you know I need to
get one of those because the burka but
you know Mikey makes them yeah burqini I
just think your muscle mass off you kind
of do look Middle Eastern ok now show
your blue hair give it away yeah but man
I don't know what when I read this I'm
like oh so jealous
yeah I was jealous of the girl cuz I'm
like she probably doesn't have a son
allergies she's she was enjoying the
water so cool during the day like I
don't know if I'd be ever bored of that
situation because that's what that's all
I want is like not have to pay for
things and then just like live like a
king for the art pain for your pain but
they said a big part of it is being
discounted right a big big part so when
you're eating it in your leg at all 10
I'm not paying a price that's almost
like free she just wanted a discount
dude the more you say that the more you
save the best things in the world are
like luxury things at a coupon at rate
mmm-hmm that's killer right there dude
imagine like you get something like like
a Lamborghini right for the price of a
table of Corolla why don't you be proud
huh do you feel as worth it
hell yeah you got a Rolex right now that
was like that if it was two cents and I
could resell that [ __ ] for 10
grand you can resell it but see you
can't resell it if I can't
no it's still it's still a real Rolex
right it's not like to Santa Rolex
what they getting a gift like a real
life well you know they still any of it
makes me feel good so for you Nadeem you
get the satisfaction of knowing a lot of
money one in two
no just sometimes the deme have to get a
hooker because he will refuse a free
[ __ ] unless I pay or she's paying
she's paying to give you a [ __ ]
oh it's like a Podrick from things five
no but it's sometimes it's like down
like this money went to of obviously I'd
rather go feel a bit this kind of stuff
oh you don't feel like you worked hard
for it not just like sometimes it's like
people would want to bribe this will
actually got for thirty five thousand
they spent the money they have it's like
that loan I bragged the opposite where I
got this [ __ ] for two cents bro
pretended like no well it's worth ten
[ __ ] you I got a deal you're not gonna
get it dude I got gym equipment for a
bag of lemons
I got a punching bag I got some [ __ ]
weights that's tight dude Dean's like
I'm not gonna buy your gym equipment
joke's on you these Jimmy this gym
equipments gonna last way longer than
those lemons at least like a week long
and these keep growing homie like next
dear I'll get more gym equipment you're
growing your own your own money there
that's a money tree right there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]